ということで今回は
横浜市金沢区のPIAフェスタというイベントに来ております。
で、このイベントの一環として今日僕ね、
ギネス記録に今回挑戦しようということで、
今から
『だるまさんがころんだ』のギネス記録にちょっと挑戦してみようと思います。
行くぞ
(歓声)
やばいwwこれはやばいww
ファン)はじめーーー!
スタッフ)では頑張っていきましょーう!
はじめ)イェーーーイ!
認定員の方)どうぞよろしくお願い致します!
(拍手)
認定員の方)ギネス世界記録をご存じない方もいらっしゃるかと思います。
認定員の方)正式名称が
『最大のだるまさんがころんだ』というものです。
本日越えなくてはならない現行記録…
448人となっております。
参加者の皆様は『だるまさんがころんだ』の大会ルールを熟知し、
ルール通りゲームに挑んでいただきます。
また、集中してゲームに参加してない人
これらの行為は失格の対象となってしまいますので、皆さんお気を付けください。
それでは、楽しむことを忘れずに世界一目指していただきたいと思います。
どうぞよろしくお願いいたします。
(拍手)
はいみなさんこんにちはー!はじめしゃちょーでーす!
(歓声)
だるまさんがころんだのギネス記録にー、えっとー、
本当に本当にたくさんの方がご参加いただいて本当に感謝しております！
本当にありがとうございます！
(拍手)
ギネス記録、あのー先ほども説明があったように、
えーと、あのー、えー参加しなかったり、動かなかったりすると！
ギネス記録に！載らないということも！起きるかもしれないので、
皆さん…
本気でだるまさんがころんだしましょーう！
わーーーーー！(歓声)
はい、OKですw
ではいきましょう！
(歓声)
せーーーの！！
参加者の方々)はじめのいーーっぽ！！
はじめ)だるまさんがころんだ！
123番、そこのこんでる447番、緑色775番、そこの小切れた青い服の人…723番
367番、368番、その隣の368番！
あとは…ああそこの106番！
だるまさんがころんだ！
おーっとー？114番、113番、283番。
682番！
あれ？うまいな…w
721番！そしてそこの赤い服778番！
今足掻いた人がいたな…そこのピンク色いパーカーの人420番。
だるまさんがころんだ！
おっとー！そこころんだ！青い服の人、280番！
108番、あっ441番今笑ったな
だるまさんがころんだ！
おっと？385番、117番！
07番、あっ295番。
だるまさんがころんだ！
だるまさんがころんだ！ストップ！
タッチした人)大股10歩でおねがいします。
はじめ)10歩？はい！じゃあ大股10歩でタッチしていきます！
いきます！
いーーーち！
にーーー！
あwバラバラww
にーーー！(さーーーん！)
さーーーん！
よーーーん！(ごーーー！)
ごーーー！
ろーーーく！(なーーーな！)
なーーーな！
はーーーち！
きゅーーーう！(あと一歩！)
はじめ)きゅう、
じゅーーーう！
スタッフ)終了でーす！
イエーーーイ！
はじめ)なんとか一回目終わったんですけども、
なかなか…タイミングが…
きれいに…だるまさんがころんだをするっていうのがちょっと難しいですね。
一発で…ギネス記録…取りに行くことになります。
今、審査が始まります。
認定員の方)まずは皆さんお疲れ様でした！
(拍手)
『The largest game of darumasan ga koronda』…
『最大のだるまさんがころんだ』というギネス世界記録に挑戦いただきました。
審査の結果…
『最大のだるまさんがころんだ』に参加された…合計人数は…
その現行記録の448名を上回る…
740名で、ギネス世界記録に認定されました！おめでとうございます！
ギネス世界記録認定になりました。おめでとうございます！